ich bin hier in zürich schlieren auf dem
weg zu alberto venzago oder der fotograf
und filmemacher schaut aktuell auf sein
werk zurück mit einer großen ausstellung
hier in zürich
glamour und erotik finden sich darin
genauso wie kriegs und enthüllungs
reportagen und sein nächstes projekt ein
kuh mit kunstfälscher wolfgang
beltracchi dazu mehr zum schluss der
sendung wissen wir doch und seine
jüngsten bilder polarisieren sind
provokativ
[Musik]
der fotograf alberto venzago kann aber
auch anders zeigt stars wie mick jagger
und penélope cruz
ganz intim oder wie lewis hamilton
vollem element aufgewachsen ist der 71
jährige in zürich in einer
deutsch-italienischen künstlerfamilie
wird als lehrer
doch der beruf langweilt ihn er bringt
sich selbst das fotografieren bei
flüchtet vom militärdienst fängt an zu
experimentieren mit der kamera und auch
mit drogen er wird kriegsreporter als
autodidakt bereits die ganze welt macht
große reportagen zb über die japanische
mafia monate lang begleitet
er geht in den iran fotografiert direkt
nach der islamischen revolution den
alltag in den straßen teherans und
dokumentiert die verheerende
kinderprostitution in den philippinen in
journalismus damals war das ein bisschen
anders als heute da konntest du drei
monate weg gehen und die haben ihr
vertrauen dass sie mit einer geschichte
zurück kommst ja und ein paar
zwischenfälle bei dieser
kinderprostitution geschichte in den
philippinen das dann ein kind umgebracht
wurde von den eltern weil es eine
schmach war da kommst du schon an
grenzen wo längst fahrt f accor hier
also was mache ich eigentlich ist mir
jetzt diese geschichte ist so wichtig
dass ich diese leben riskieren
immerhin die reportage führt in
deutschland zu einem neuen gesetz kind
missbräuche können nun auch dort
strafrechtlich verfolgt werden
als er dem nazi schlechter klaus barbie
fotografisch in südamerika auf der spur
ist wird er entdeckt und entgeht nur
knapp einem anschlag
ein wendepunkt venzago entscheidet sich
dafür nur noch zu inszenieren
[Musik]
oft pompös und auch kontrovers wie die
inszenierung seiner frau julia vorging
irritierend pornographisch fast
[Musik]
das ist ja so dass ich wirklich wohnen
und arbeiten die das battle nichts
richtiges büro so zahlen kunden
arbeitsplatz ist das urteil scharf
das ist eigentlich im moment nichts zu
verlieren um stetig das heißt er
bescheinigt kunst und beschäftigt mit
möglichen kosten acht nhl aufstellung
war schon zwei claudia schneider sitzen
danke überlegen zumal das ist so im
vorteil aber durchschaut ist das ist
total energie zwischen arbeit und
privatleben
aber so hat sie immer funktioniert es
ist e mails tokio gibt es hätten sich
mache ich fünf jahre lang ist an kredite
kommt dann kommt sie finden reisende
show maxi und letzte jahr ist alles wie
in größte glück sonst
und ich will meine single sexy mit
lantinus nächste für eine ganz fertig
bin ich am nächsten und jetzt zu hunger
wurde halt manchmal als stopper muss
rücklage unterfangen archiv
so ein spiel angst nicht einmal zu
machen sagen sie ich denke meine mama
dass man das gemacht hat und das ist 14
und jetzt habe ich praktisch wäre genug
stellen geschaffen als verrückt ist
bildet hector wiegand gilt also die
fotografien und ich aus einem passieren
das bild vom luxus pils die erinnerung
hat wir haben alle viel stillstand
erlebt nicht nur 2020 auch nochmal 20 21
aber diese zwangspause die kann auch
unter kreativer pause verbucht werden
für kunst und kultur also ganz wie bei
alberto venzago wir schauen zurück
leere museen
leere kinos leere theater
stillstand keineswegs
die zwangspause entpuppte sich als
kreative blaupause ich würde ich gut
ich würde ich suche du musst ein bild an
machen kannst du jetzt bist du
eingefroren
mach mal dein bild an ich würde ich soll
ich dich mal so richtig über sumann
ruhig und gut machen was ihr virus
hahaha wir sind schließlich auch noch da
so das schauspielhaus zürich
das ein großes angebot an online
streaming veranstaltungen auf die beine
stellt
ja das ist ja das paradoxe also ich als
theaterleiter fand das wahnsinnig
anstrengend als künstler war das für
mich eine sehr produktive zeit also das
ist ein dankbares thema weil es ja auch
so viele menschen angeht es gibt es ja
selten dass ein thema so kollektiv alle
betrifft und dass man auf einmal von
individuellen erfahrung sprechen kann
die tatsächlich jetzt mal in der zeit
für sehr sehr viele menschen gelten für
sich allein dasselbe erleben wie viele
andere vor ihren screens auf dem sofa so
erging es auch dem publikum der
solothurner filmtage und dann noch
erfolgreich
125000 zuschauerinnen erreichte das
programm
die solothurner altstadt hingegen bei
unserem besuch fast unheimlich leer
die kinokassen namen hier nichts ein
doch auch hier reagierte man kreativ und
unkompliziert auf die notlage
festivaldirektorin anita rogy
entwickelte gemeinsam mit der
filmbranche eine ad hoc idee sehr
wichtig sei dass mehrere neue situation
aber nur lose kind führt online
auswärtige firmen
das heißt ein sogenannter
solidaritätsbeitrag of thrones verdammt
die ganze film studiert auch keine
bekommen hat jetzt nicht lange und zieht
aus fertig und dann mit der beteiligung
nicht alles aber funktioniert mit video
streams gleich gut
preisverleihungen waren auch schon
glamouröser das preisgeld aber war
dieses jahr vielleicht so notwendig wie
nie zuvor in dieser zeit jetzt hilft
diese preis mir auch dass ich für eine
weile finanziell unabhängig weiter
schreiben kann und das bedeutet mir sehr
viel
und so ging es schlag auf schlag online
das gebot der stunde dass and four music
festival lancierte sogar seinen
nachwuchs wettbewerb digital die
virtuelle kommunikation aber ganz im
sinne der digital natives war auch für
junge teilnehmende eine herausforderung
[Musik]
für die festival direktion war der
wettbewerb auf distanz neuland der wille
aber etwas inspirierend schönes zu
bieten um so größer
ich glaube es ist trotzdem gutes stück
weg vor staaten intimität hersteller und
zu mir ich sagen trotz allem seelische
kinos kommt
[Musik]
immerhin die gewinnerband bethpage
durfte den begehrten preis physisch
abholen
dass all die digitale kommunikation die
physische präsenz nicht ersetzen kann
spürten alle video calls mögen effizient
sein machen aber auch einsam
überraschend gerade jugendliche kämpften
mit der sozialen distanz allein in der
schweiz fühlen sich fast 50 prozent von
ihnen regelmäßig einsam marina harz hat
dieses gefühl studiert ihr buch über die
einsamkeit hochaktuell
vielleicht ist dieses kollektive
experiment der isolation eine gute sache
damit wir mehr darüber sprechen und die
leute zu geben können wie schwer es ist
sich isoliert zu fühlen
das isolation auch gutes hervorbringen
kann
das zeigte sich am kunstmarkt die
traditionell so vom physischen objekt
abhängige branche wurde endlich digital
die viel größere umwälzung aber dürften
die nft es sein bilderbibel several days
gibt es nicht in echt sind nur digitale
dateien und dennoch ist der
us-amerikaner mit dem verkauf des werkes
für fast 70 millionen dollar
der zweitteuerste noch lebende künstler
sag jetzt mal nfc im allgemeinen ist ein
futter größte schockmoment für kunst
welt und auch eines der größten
revolutionen seitdem duchamp revolution
oder nur strohfeuer
die teuer verkauften bilder mission auf
denn mit dem neuen medium kommt eine
neue bildsprache dass es wie eine
parallelwelt die völlig entkoppelt ist
von den fragestellungen die in
kunstgeschichte kunstkritik und
künstlerischer produktion in den letzten
jahren virulent waren deswegen würde ich
fast so weit gehen und sagen das sieht
für mich manchmal wie nicht kunst aus
ich fühle mich erinnert an ein poster
shop in santa fe während die kunstwelt
über die relevanz der enev hieß erst mal
diskutieren muss hat sich die situation
um corona bereits ein wenig entspannt
das stück das nicolas stemann während
des lockouts geschrieben hat kommt
endlich raus im wahrsten sinne des
wortes
[Musik]
dieses projekt zeigt wie ja
gewissermaßen auch wie ein virus ja wie
die kunst sich verschiedene bühnen und
eben dann immer wieder sucht also die
kunst kriegen sie nicht tot und klar
wünscht man sich dass die systemrelevanz
von kunst irgendwie durchgehende erkannt
wird
noch gelten einige corona maßnahmen
doch schon in der juni kann mehr
publikum an bord geholt werden
[Musik]
wir sind das da die letzten
vorbereitungen für die große ausstellung
zum glück dass die wirtschaft das ziel
gerade jetzt nach all der monatelange
schaffen und soll sich alle gefreut
jetzt könne zurückweichen drucker für
den ausdruck die bilder aber da der
südlichen riesa luxus dass ich als
fotograf paul sahner machen also vom
auslöser von bildbearbeiter und auch
ausdruck der ganze ablauf wahrscheinlich
fand es ist das 13
also jetzt wird er dort sei natürlich
das bild ausdruck dass ich nach können
aber vielleicht ist gar noch nie gut und
das ist wie früher in der dunkelkammer
mit dem rot wird der die nichts anderes
event velits mit handwärmer gemacht oder
rasche abdeckt und so und witzig auf
digital aber letztendlich ist das bild
wieder anders als physisches bilder
nicht liegen wir im bildschirm
das risiko scheint ein logo das in die
zuschauer viel ist aber doch keiner
hatte vielleicht vierte sturm
[Musik]
die antithese vor dem überinszeniert das
sind die früheren eine fotoreportage wo
sie gemacht der philippinen
kinderprostitution bis mich was ich am
meisten berührt hat mir am meisten in
erinnerung blieb wie kann man sollte bis
verarbeiter es ist ich habe vor der zeit
richtig sie und haben den krieg machten
das ist natürlich harry deprimieren
beobachter durchaus nie aktiv und
besitzt habe ich vielleicht zwei wochen
in guatemala ordering im iran als er mir
ab und was weis ich habe ihm sehr gut
und da bin ich mir sicher nach pcs mit
der assistentin gang dass ich auch nicht
in einem freien szene und mit einem
seitenschneider das mini lag ich mir
einfach ist wie die miete wegen schüssen
kam ja und wie du bist ein beobachter
abs wie die rallyes krunke und das ist
ja pervers und roxy von life magazin
extra gemacht dass über unordnung zu und
dann bin ich zwei jahre später nach
münchen haben in die bilder zeigen
12 11 9 jährigen absicherung von denen
50 60 jährige frau war also das ist
pornografie und ziehen konnten ein taxi
spannenden tag sehen wir ja wie die
nackt sind ganz und gar nicht kapiert
was ist eigentlich und mit dem stern
gang und die angst dass ich unglaublich
machen wir sofort sind groß publiziert
und dass ich sehr mag sie wie harry
potter stadtsprechers bilder so viel
material ihres ganz fertig kann man auch
gutes trilogie was sind das alles die
jetzt dass das sind alles die ganze
geschichte
sind denn die reise täten sie das ist
wie krieg mit explosion nicht gekommen
es ist einfach groß ist ja alles voran
aber es geht natürlich sache aber nicht
so einen respektabel ist will ich kraft
nicht ganz machen und das ist die
geschichte mini ältere ihrem tod
begleitet eine also für mich ja mit
reden kommen wir haben das ist ja gut
wie fertig langweg sich vor der familie
als ich dann von ihrer mutter hat
vergangenes jahr bekannt eine immobilie
müssen für wohnen frankfurt ist bin ich
tatsächlich wieder grosse kammer wichtig
sie der kamera
sie ist in ihren dienst will sich felix
endlich merken sich und hat ein
ungerechtes kapitän und das ist das
ritual wurde zum herz fahrer filme und
der bin zu meiner mutter und hat
nachgefragt aber zum snack west
voneinander also nie erzählt aber das
ist sicher eine bis kino und
fernsehfilme und für münchen das blatt
und das ist genau was runden arbeiten
sagen und wieder eine sehr witzige was
kommt als nächstes passiert präsident
kriegen also das ist wichtige projekt
also jetzt zum beispiel mit dem wolfgang
beltracchi haben ganz tolle geschichte
das wird mich für den exzessen und
erschwert beschäftigen und was ist das
fragt
weil die leider noch nicht so viel sehr
genau richtigen namen keine tram sie
kennen bestimmt die fabelhafte
geschichte des wolfgang beltracchi
jahrzehntelang fälschte er meisterhaft
kunstwerke von rembrandt bis picasso
verkaufte sie für millionen
dann flog er auf saß im gefängnis heute
lebt er in der schweiz und plant sein
nächstes großes ding mit alberto venzago
[Musik]
was ist mein schäfer sieht man im system
wenn sage was ist dann ihr rezept einmal
gut zu fotografieren einmal wie wolfgang
der sehr kreativ ist ja da bin ich
natürlich gefordert auch kreativ sein
dass es sich ein bisschen ergänzt ich
bin einfach wie ein schatten wenn er
malt ja ich bin da aber eigentlich doch
nicht da und er ist immer im fluss ist
in bewegung das heißt die kamera muss ja
etwas ähnliches machen also ich
fotografiere nicht mit stativ um den
licht sondern ganz anders und wird und
ich bin danach in der wenn mit dem
pinsel fährt und zwar diese bewegungen
so das ist einfach so und manchmal ist
er meistens nicht 90 verwischt oder die
hand ist schon fertig weil das was er
soll und das ist das ist erstaunlich
ihr habt ein gemeinsames projekt oder
ist ja leider kunstaffine lass mich mal
raten sie ist denn das gemeinsame
projekt ja also wenn ich an malerei
denke und ihr macht ja kein kleines ding
so wie ich euch einschätzen das ist ein
richtig großes ding also was war nochmal
das teuerste gemälde der welt lasst mich
überlegen eine 400 millionen dollar 450
salvator mundi ja wird leonardo da vinci
zugeschriebenen nicht wolfgang
beltracchi habe ich nicht gewollt noch
nicht
kein test nahmen mit was zu tun haben
das könnte was mit leonardo zu tun habe
beschäftige mich schon lange ist der
experte
also wo trefft ihr euch malerei
fotografie ja salvator mundi wo es
schnittstellen eine schnittstelle liegt
natürlich eigentlich bei der fotografie
sich vorzustellen wie die werte der
ausgesehen lästerte wie hätte er
ausgesehen wenn ich bin jetzt malen
würde zum beispiel oder wenn leonardo
ihn wirklich gemalt hätte
wir hätte ausgesehen das ist ja eine
frage mich stellt sich jeder oder
wie würde er war euch aussehen ja so wie
leonardo gegen malta muss man abwarten
und sich dann an ort ich lass euch da
weiter konspirativ köpfe zusammenstecken
[Musik]
die große retrospektive von alberto
venzago können sie sehen auf dem 19 juni
im zürcher museum für gestaltung mit
dieser sendung verabschieden wir uns vom
kulturplatz in die sommerpause und sehen
uns aber wieder am 18
ja ganz zum schluss schauen wir noch mal
zurück auf eine zeit die wir nicht so
schnell vergessen mitten in der krise
haben wir kunstschaffende eingeladen
sich bei uns zu zeigen
wir wollten eine bühne sein als die
anderen bühnen dunkel blieben davon
jetzt noch ein best-of für sie und dann
von herzen ganz viel sommer corona
stoppte alles nur nicht die kreativität
für unseren wettbewerb srf samstag
gingen über 60 projekte bei uns ein
und blieb nur die qual der wahl welche
projekte wir in der sendung zeigen
wollen zb hanna lin group mitten in der
pandemie kam das erste buch der
zwölfjährigen heraus fast gleichzeitig
wie das neue buch ihrer mutter und
autorin stefanie kurzerhand
organisierten sie online lesungen und
trugen ihre geschichten so von der stube
in die welt hinaus
[Musik]
genug von stetiger proberaum luft hatte
die band dill und kraut und gab uns
exklusiv ein konzert zwischen
bahngleisen auf der bühne aber virtuell
so trat das kabarettisten duo
schertenleib und jäger lena auf und das
jeden donnerstag im theater burgdorf die
band frag nicht begeisterte uns mit
ihren texten zwischen dada 80er jahre
deutsche welle und sozialkritik
[Musik]
das ist sowieso unserem herz liegt dass
man so tragen zu unserem habe das
renaissance auch hochmodern klingen kann
davon überzeugte uns das junge ensemble
concerto scirocco
und auch die tänzerin miriam baraka ließ
es sich nicht nehmen trotz schottern auf
der bühne zu stehen
[Musik]
es ist für mich mir noch schnell was ich
bin zwar schied sie ohne die ganzen die
bewegung und aber irgendwie trotzdem
immer tanzen das ist mir im blut
[Musik]
und last but not least engagierte
klangkünstler julia nicht nur seine
familie sondern auch dazugehörigen haus
hat die dem stück regie sondern in der
korona konform art von musik zu machen
kreativ sein im lok dann bloß verstarb
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur ist
reese los